you
moment of the sexual experience we'll
ask the young lady who's your daddy this
should be remixed if officer akimov is
watching this could be the next remix
masterpiece dude because just wait till
you see what happens here oh officer
officer akimov is here uh that's
beautiful
who's your dad i'm joined today by
pastor james david manning
oh i'm a christian
[Music]
i'm joined today by pastor james david
manning
[Music]
is the most successful
on planet earth to reverence the word of
god to trust it to preach it to teach it
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus
[Music]
bush
and george bush jr have been penetrated
by at least 100 men in their
a hundred thousand two hundred thousand
strong i didn't do it that's not my
problem well i got down on my knees
i didn't do it i was tempted
sounds like quite an evening
[Music]
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads of money and tons and tons of
lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
me say something to you about marketing
[Music]
starbucks has done the exact same thing
that coca-cola has done except they've
done it with semen
that certainly seems to be a story that
has been missed
[Music]
[Music]
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.99
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
is
[Music]
flippy from indiana
flippy from indiana please unmute you
are on the air my friend all right can
you hear me
yes i can
hey david it's me um i just was
wondering if you've ever reconsidered
making only fans sorry if i if i've done
making an omelette what no no making an
only fans uh you know uh earning season
is over and it's time for you to show us
your zucchini
that's very clever no listen um i think
i'd i'd be more likely
uh i'd be more likely to show my my
granny smith apples than any zooks
floppy dukes
dumps they call them dumps big massive
dumps
[Music]
big massive dumps
[Applause]
big massive dump
[Music]
big massive dumpster
[Music]
in michigan and pennsylvania huge dumps
in michigan and pennsylvania
huge dumps
in michigan and pennsylvania huge dumps
big massive dumps
huge dumps were happening all over the
country
what is going on here big massive dumb
huge dumps were happening all over the
country
what is going on here big massive dumps
the fbi and department of justice i
don't know maybe they're involved and
i'm sure you felt that way that i'm sure
you felt that way
the fbi and department of justice i
don't know maybe they're involved they
call them dumb
big massive dumps
you're a laughingstock
[Music]
huge dumpster in michigan and
pennsylvania huge dumps
in michigan and pennsylvania
[Music]
in michigan and pennsylvania huge dumps
big massive dumps
[Music]
big massive dump
all right wow welcome everybody what an
introduction really couldn't uh
couldn't hope for anything better than
that quite frankly what a day
um so we were originally scheduled to
have just the town hall today at 6 pm
eastern 3 pacific
now you might be looking at a clock and
saying sir it's not six o'clock and you
would be right but because yesterday we
achieved we unlocked another stream
today by getting not only to a hundred
yesterday but to 104
on our
member
and twitch counter
i committed
to this heretofore unannounced stream in
addition to the 6pm
town hall so the town hall is happening
that's going to be in about an hour and
20 minutes i hope you all join us
everybody is welcome we're opening the
phone lines via discord um that however
will only be streaming on the pacman
live youtube channel it's not going to
be streaming on facebook's it's not
going to be on tick tocks it won't be on
the main youtube channel and it won't be
on twitch
the town hall in an hour and 19 minutes
will only be
on the pacman live youtube channel as
previously promoted not a not a joke
uh
it's just what it is by the way how are
the calzones right
so that's going to be at 6 pm
everybody's welcome to participate if
you're a website member you will get
priority access you are you are
basically
we estimate about six and a half times
as likely to get on with me
if you are a website member but it is
open to all it will be via discord so
that's happening a little bit later
today okay
um
what else oh
and
if we again once again if we again get
to 100 website members in twitch today
then we will guarantee a stream tomorrow
and i've said we will go all the way up
to and including a new year's eve stream
um
it's up to you it's up to you so we're
gonna have it all happening
what is happening with the dr fauci
attacks
they're completely out of control
yesterday oh oh and by the way i do have
a satsuma mandarin which we i also
committed i would open up
um
on stream today thanks to us getting to
a hundred members okay so we do have i
have a satsuma here with its um thick
loose uh skin
so that's gonna be a little bit later
okay we'll get to that i do have it
sitting down here
um
yesterday i mentioned that dr fauci was
asked
what about a vaccine mandate for getting
on an airplane
and he said well it's reasonable
it's reasonable
and the right has gone completely crazy
they want fauci fired they now all of a
sudden care about coveted cases and
deaths the daily mail a right-wing sort
of rag quite frankly um put together
this uh kind of like an attack article
talking about um
fauci admits the administration failed
to distribute enough covid tests and all
these different things
um
so they're they're basically doing the
full attack
on fouchy at this point in time and
remember that dr fauci even said i don't
think it's likely that we're doing this
it's just like it would be reasonable to
require a vaccine
to get on an airplane would would be
reasonable but
i don't think it's likely to happen the
way things are going and they are just
going completely crazy they want him
fired they want him uh some people
actually want him imprisoned and
prosecuted
that's not gonna happen
and i think it was drudge
yeah now fauci pushes domestic travel
vacs rule
817 kova deaths on his watch
where were these headlines when we had
what 600 000 under trump or whatever it
was 81 years old is it time to go
um
so they're really really really going
wild with this now some interesting
headlines i will mention
uh oh some these are slightly off screen
for which i apologize
omicron may cut delta infections study
shows which is very very interesting
um
global infections highest ever we talked
about that
children's hospitals filling up we
talked about that
biden now declares no federal solution
to the pandemic
that i actually think was a mistake for
biden to lay out now
biden federal solution it does seem sort
of hypocritical when you run on fixing
kovid and then now you say actually it's
really kind of up to the states let me
see if i can find
the where was the um where was that clip
actually biden fed oh here it is okay
look there is no
federal solution this gets solved at a
state level yeah and and uh people
pointing out that that cough is still
going on
um
yeah
so that's all uh
it's it's i think it's a strategic
mistake i mean the truth is it's sort of
like all along
all along
it was not just going to be able to be
the federal government that solved this
and we saw early
when governors weren't cooperating
things went downhill and downhill and
downhill
but when you run on i will fix it and
then you say it's really up to the
governors
it's a problem it's a it's a problem
without any doubt um dr fauci
seems to also and this was so obvious
yesterday we talked about these new
guidelines that the cdc rolled out for
when people can return to work after an
omicron infection
and it seemed at least 50 economically
motivated and in fact a bunch of doctors
tweeted there's really no evidence for
doing
this there's no medical evidence it
seems to be economic fouchy seems to be
saying in this clip it is to get people
back to work faster
oh wait a second where oh it's muted
hold on unmute here we go well the
reason is that with the with the sheer
volume of new cases
that we are having and that we expect to
continue with omicron one of the things
we want to be careful of is that we
don't have so many people out i mean
obviously if you have symptoms you
should not be out but if you are
asymptomatic and you are infected we
want to get people back to the jobs
particularly those with essential jobs
to keep our society running smoothly now
notice that
there's nothing in there
about the medical reasoning and when you
look at the cdc guidelines on this
they're pretty soft and squishy in terms
of what is the
they say what the guidelines are but
they don't really explain why and and it
it seems like this is just an economic
thing mostly and you know airlines were
begging for this recently so i think
that was a very prudent and good choice
on the part of the cdc which we spent a
considerable amount of time discussing
namely getting people back in half the
time than they would have been out so
that they can get back to the workplace
doing things that are important to keep
society running smoothly now understand
he makes three economic statements but
no medical statements uh it's only 47
seconds let's play it again
see if you can hear the medical
justification for this now i'm not even
taking like a strong position against it
it may be fine but but i'm just not
seeing the medical explanation well the
reason is that with the with the sheer
volume of new the reason is the sheer
volume of cases cases
that we are having and that we expect to
continue with omicron one of the things
we want to be careful of is that we
don't have so many people out
i mean obviously if you have symptoms
you should not be out so
there's a lot of cases and we got to be
really careful that not too many people
are staying home from work
that's what it is so far but if you are
asymptomatic and you are infected we
want to get people back to the jobs
particularly those with essential jobs
to keep our society running smoothly so
let's get people back to work to keep
society running smoothly
there's no we've determined that
nobody's gonna get sick the cdc did say
it appears that with omicron
you're most contagious in the first day
or two before symptoms
and in the two to three days after they
start so
that's that's what's been been said but
it doesn't seem to have been proven
empirically yet so i think that was a
very prudent and good choice
on the part of the cdc which we spent a
considerable amount of time discussing
namely getting people back
in half the time than they would have
been out so that they can get back to
the workplace it's like the goal is the
explanation
think about that he says well
you know
the reason we want to do this is so that
we don't have a lot of people out
so that we can get everybody back to
work more quickly it's like okay so
that's the motivation but what's the
medical explanation okay all right we're
not gonna belabor it but that's uh that
that's what it is from dr fauci um i
want to say thank you to clinton jones
for signing up on my website
joinedpakman.com
and chris lenish for signing up on my
website new members 1 and 2 today as i
mentioned earlier if we fill the bar to
100 i will commit to a third stream in a
row and we're willing to do it all the
way up up up to end including new year's
eve over on twitch i want to say thank
you to astrolycos
greenman
scientis
and margot cabot
with twitch prime subscriptions putting
us at six and then as a reminder today
do not adjust your television today is
the day of the viewer town hall it's the
last one of the year it'll be at 6 00 pm
eastern this is a pre-town hall stream
the town hall will be at the top of the
next hour
only on the pacman live youtube channel
so make sure that you are subscribed
over there because this is where the
town hall will will take place it won't
be on the main youtube channel it won't
be on twitch it won't be on facebook
it's open to all but if you want an even
better chance of getting on get a
website membership somewhere between a
six and seven times more likely
possibility uh of getting on with me if
you are a website member and on that
note thanks to havana for gifting two
subs via twitch putting us at eight um
okay if you watch my streams and my
content regularly
you know that i joke around a lot about
different food elements and um
restaurants and you know fruits and deli
and all these different things
um it's always like 90 percent joking
and it is true that i haven't been to a
fast food restaurant in like 18 years or
something like that and i don't think
very highly of them as well as places
like applebee's and olive garden and
chili's and so on and so forth but the
degree to which right wingers who
couldn't
care less about economic justice and
equality they couldn't care less about
it as soon as i tweet anything about
applebee's being horrible
they jump out and say oh my god you're
attacking poor people you're attacking
the all and and of course they have no
idea what the context is which is this
is like an ongoing gag on the show but
check this out this is just amazing
i tweeted
because of all these different burger
king people whoa uh we'll get to that
all these people getting themselves
arrested at burger king and applebee's
and all these different things i tweeted
earlier why do all the anti-vaxxers
anti-masters get themselves arrested at
applebee's burger king never any serious
restaurants what does it all mean and
it's like it's 90 percent a joke 95 a
joke
and also
and also
it's sort of serious in that there's
definitely a cultural element here where
they they don't trust the vaccine it
might have chemicals it might have all
these different things but then they go
and shove processed food in their faces
without thinking about what the
ingredients are what's in there high
fructose corn syrup extenders for meat
all this different stuff
it's a joke and it also has like a
serious element of like wait it's like
the people who smoke cigarettes but
don't want the vaccine same type of
thing okay so look at some of these
responses this is this is just the best
um
let's look at some of these here
uh
those restaurants are serious to me
man a lot of the attack ones aren't even
showing up here that's weird
burger king is a great restaurant sad
it's trending for the wrong reason where
were all the people who were attacking
me hold on a second
i open carry at arby's
let's see if we can find them here
so virginia hume i don't know who that
is but she's got a blue check because
less than two percent of restaurants are
white tablecloth
and of course we're not talking about
white tablecloth
um
why do you why you hate on the bougie
pros
they love being ironic about being
concerned about what they put in their
body
man where are the the i think the issue
is there's so many of these responses
that i'm having so oof you know people
thought i was i was being rude here
the political elites on both sides of
the aisle have figured out how to keep
the rest of us fighting with each other
so we're preoccupied therefore too tied
and busy to see what's really happening
and get rid of them
it's about access and affordability what
is a serious restaurant
serious restaurant wow really david wow
david how's that bubble you live in
um
what's so bad about applebee's or burger
king brunch lib
i do like brunch that's true
don't forget cheesecake factory though
that may be considered a serious
restaurant
look at all the pores you know this type
of stuff
the lower class are the ones most
affected by mandates shock right you
know what's funny applebee's isn't even
cheap
applebee's menu prices
it's not even super cheap
like you know they've got fourteen
dollar appetizers
eighteen dollar shrimp and parm sirloin
like a local taco place
where it's actually local food
is cheaper and it's better so it's not
it's not even a pricing thing that's
what's really strange about it it really
is a cultural thing okay the burgers are
11 bucks or nine bucks
you know at a more more bougie burger
place there's definitely more
um anyway
whatever so that's what it is that's the
that that was what happened as far as uh
applebee's is concerned someone sent me
this they said this is what i was would
look like if i wasn't jewish which is
kind of interesting actually
um
yeah i mean it's like
what have they actually modified i guess
my eye color
they seem to have shrunk my nose a
little bit a little bit of a different
beard
this is non-jewish david pakman
i don't know what people think about
that
yeah oh and people are saying chili's
chili's menu prices how expensive is
chili's that's a good question
let's see
like what is a what does a stake cost
you
oh we don't know okay
probably have to enter in a bunch of
different information oh chile with menu
prices
ooh they've got fried pickles for 7.50
that's not bad
lighter choices
yeah see this is funny like the fajita
trio is 17 bucks at chili's
it's 15 at
you know my local
actual legit mexican place
so it's not it's really not even a price
thing the burrito's 11 bucks it's nine
at my local place
uh that's what's interesting that they
start talking about price but it's
really not about it's not about price by
the way how are the calzones yeah
exactly
um all right we're gonna look at this
video momentarily if you're just joining
us we do have the stream coming at the
top of the hour i want to say thank you
to graham lych for signing up on my
website joinpakman.com graham is new
member number nine today
also want to say thanks to apponaut
and bonemaster jay
who have subscribed via twitch
and our new members 10 and 11 as we did
yesterday we are doing it again today if
we fill this up to 100
we will guarantee another stream
tomorrow and i'm willing to stream every
day through the end of the year that's
up to and including new year's eve but
it's only if we get to 100. otherwise
we're taking tomorrow off um the alex
jones what alex jones claims is a
betrayal from donald trump continues
here is alex jones um
well let's just listen to alex jones
alex jones really losing it recently
after donald trump said hey the
vaccine's good persecuted for supporting
trump it makes it 10 times worse because
i know podesta's evil and i know
hillary's evil i know obama's evil and i
know falci's evil i know bill gates is
evil and i know they're all evil
but trump did a lot of good and i
believed in him and so the fact that
he's done this makes it personal it
makes it hurt now is he talking about
what trump said about the vaccine is
that what he means
let me see if i can find any more clips
from this rant
so this is the one we just looked at
this one we looked at yesterday
let's see what this one's about and i'm
not even bitching i'm trying to
understand why i'm the worst
communicator
got a better job
okay get your ass together now
i'm serious i suck
[Music]
freaking killing everybody everybody's
in a trance
all right let's go to rebroadcast for a
while
i'm serious man i'm two inches folks
from walking out here forever oh i
thought yeah i thought he meant
something else when he said i'm two
inches
can't do this anymore man
we're in a damn war they're murdering
everybody
it's funny
well i don't think it's funny
[Music]
wow what a weird clip um
here is a mega activist
on alex jones show talking also about
the vaccine a lot of you are probably
gonna say oh well i don't care what he
does because this is about medical
freedom as long as we have the choice
he's not even giving you the choice if
you go to his hotel in new york you have
to show proof of papers so how can you
continue to blindly defend this man i
don't get it make it make sense please
trump do some great things while in
office absolutely was i a supporter i
was a huge one
but there's no denying that what he is
doing is evil
and if we continue to just support
someone that does not have our best
interest then that makes us no better
than the left we have to be willing to
come out and state when there's a
problem and i personally think that
there is a huge problem so it's time to
stop trusting the plan it's time to wake
the [ __ ] up because nobody is coming to
save you and this is 100
wow they've completely turned on trump
this is amazing
uh here's another one
take credit for it's a great what we've
done is history
shine on to it take credit for it take
just sign on believe it
i mean hell we're we're fighting bill
gates and fauci and biden and the new
world order and sake and and and and and
the debose group and and peter dazek and
now we got trump on their team
take credit for it's agreement wow and
then here's one more children with
deadly poison everywhere that they know
erases their immune system and trump is
running around in a stupid red tie
playing the part of the apprentice ceo
now what i i need to make sure i say
this because you have to rebut
there is no evidence whatsoever for the
things alex jones is saying here
telling everybody oh you're playing into
their hands not taking their shot no
trump
you are playing into their hands and
destroying yourself and signing yourself
onto the new world order
and that idiot bill o'reilly what a
pervert doesn't even know how to pick
women up it's just
it's all just an incredible joke
see
i i just can't get mad on there anymore
you know there's a greg race report
there's a great race report that you
just followed that's so important
and so let's just air that
and i may just go to re-broadcast i'm
not trying to be dramatic here i just
i may just never come back you know i
mean seriously just let everybody have
what you want let ship and pelosi rob
you let him molest your children
there is no evidence that adam schiff or
nancy pelosi have ever molested anyone
your four-year-olds away and chop their
genitals off you love it
everybody's too busy with their own life
and their own thing and their own this
and their own candy-ass bs to wake up
out of the coma that there is a satanic
off-world alien attack going on on this
point that is that q anon stuff right
there
i mean you look at it you analyze it
this ain't human
and you people need to wake up and rally
against it or maybe we are a bad species
maybe this thing wiping us out is good
i just know this there is an advanced
intelligence run in this damn thing and
it's sophisticated
and there's all these delusional people
going along with i think it's funny i
think it's cute and it's not cute i
don't care if you're donald trump i
don't care if you're bill gates i don't
care who you are you come at children
with experimental nuremberg code
violating vaccines the vaccines are do
not violate the nuremberg code and the
pfizer vaccine is fully approved and by
definition is not experimental cepheid
suffer high okay
so there's that we're gonna move on to
the burger king stuff momentarily um i
see people asking are there still free
t-shirts available there are okay so
listen
here are the options right now let me
set this up for you 57 minutes from now
is today's viewer town hall
everyone is welcome to call in
the town hall will be streaming only on
the pacman live youtube channel but
everybody is welcome to call in
um
members on my website have their own
way to call in
and get priority so
regardless of how you sign up at
joinpacman.com you get priority now here
are the options that you have
if you just want to get a discount the
biggest discount right now is with the
coupon code obama
the spelling is above my head okay you
get a membership you get the bonus show
you get the commercial free audio video
stream all that stuff and priority on
the town hall and you use the coupon
code
for the discount no t-shirt though
if you want a free t-shirt this is
available through new year's eve
you pay full price for the year so
not monthly i get people who sign up
with a code paying a dollar a month and
then they go sir send me the t-shirt
t-shirt cuts cost us 20 bucks you know
we're not trying to lose money here the
idea is to fund raise not fund
leak
um
if you pay full price for a year email
info davidpakman.com
will get you a free t-shirt okay either
way it counts here
either way it counts here and uh
if we get to 100 there will be a stream
tomorrow along those lines
alexander albrecht has just signed up
with the coupon code
and his new member number 12 today
thank you alexander you are a great
person i also want to say thanks to
swayla only or maybe it's sway la
only and nolan
for signing up via twitch prime putting
us at 14 it's both
website memberships and twitch prime
both count
use the bezos box
and remember
just the website memberships get you
priority access on the town hall 55
minutes from now i hope that that's all
clear
uh
i want clarity this evening
actually that's a funny meme do you guys
remember that guy phil
davison this guy was nuts
um
this used to be such a great thing
let's see phil davison clarity let me
see
uh
rant
speech
some of our man i don't know who this
guy is
but uh
was it phil davison or davidson let me
see if i can find it some of our viewers
might be too young to even know about
this oh here it is that was the guy
actually hold on
phil davison
start county treasurer yeah here it is
oh it's davidson
no it is davison
oh here it is
i think this is it this is really
memetic history ladies and gentlemen of
the star county republican party
executive committee good evening
and thank you
not only for your attendance
but for allowing me the opportunity to
speak
this is the best my name is phil davison
and i am seeking our party's nomination
for the position of star county
treasurer
on november 10th
november of 2010 excuse
me in terms of my background
i am from the village of minerva this
guy this is this is this is just not
really unbelievable
where i am serving my 13th year
as
of elected service as a minerva council
member
in terms of education
i have a bachelor's degree in sociology
a bachelor's degree in history
a master's degree in public
administration
you know master's degree in
communication
i don't know why he pauses like that
before mentioning the final degree
but there's something incredible about
it
in terms of elections across star county
i have represented our party twice on
the county ballot
in both the primary in the general
elections when i ran for star county
clerk of courts in 1996 and star county
commissioner in 2000 and i will not
apologize for my tone tonight
i have been a republican in times good
and i have been a republican and time's
bad
albert einstein issued one of my most
favorite quotes in the history of the
spoken word and it is as follows
in the middle of opportunity
excuse me in the middle of difficulty
lies of opportunity i'm going to repeat
that so i have clarity tonight there's
the key line what difficulty lies
opportunity
this is the opportunity we've been
waiting okay anyway that's phil that's
phil davidson
davison davison it is phil davison so
that's that we we could we can move on
but that is really really something else
he it's the picture of stability quite
frankly i want to say thank you to
christine sterling christine thank you
also thanks to ian dunham
both of whom signed up on my website
using the coupon code obama
numbers 15 and 16 also thanks to jimmy
stanley jimmy stanley just grabbed a
membership on my website
very much appreciate that
uh okay let's get to the burger king
stuff i have so many of these videos to
look at
um
they oh wait hold on do we do we should
we do that or should we do the satsuma
next
i don't know what people want to do next
the satsuma
yeah we could do the setsu maybe it just
makes sense to do that
all right let's do that real quick okay
so yesterday i mentioned this is this is
the best citrus fruit
um it's a satsuma mandarin
i don't know why but people ask that i
open one here so i'm gonna describe to
you what i'm doing the the the skin is
so
loose that as you can see
it's it's it's flaccid and a lot of
people would pick this up
and they would think it's rotten and by
the way the i don't know why that's
looking green on screen it's just
overexposed it's just too close to the
light oh there we go i'm going to back
it up
um
so you would look it's a lot of people
would look at this and think it must be
rancid because it's so soft but i'm
going to show you
it just
so easily opens
why does it look like that on camera
that's bizarre
the hell
man that's crazy
okay
oh it's the green screen oh i see okay
so anyway let's open this thing up
see it just peels so easily
and you look at these
there's like a weird chroma key thing
happening with it let me see if i can
put it
back here oh okay if i keep it in front
of my head i think it's better there we
go
so
you just go like this and these are just
absolutely perfect segments i mean the
anatomy of these things is unbelievable
it's incredible that this is even legal
and uh yeah let's just take a segment of
it
i usually get rid of a bunch of the pith
but some people leave it
um
but anyway
that's a perfect fruit
that is a i i do think this is the best
citrus fruit
let's try one more segment
see so there it is
just perfect
unbelievable
just really i mean it's shocking that
it's even legal
it really is
that's called a slice i thought they
were called orange segments
that's weird
okay all right thank you very much
everybody i appreciate it all right
let's uh let's let's keep going here so
let's start looking at some of these
clips uh new york anti-vaxxers some
wearing martin luther king imagery storm
a burger king to protest vaccine
mandates and start swearing at each
other then nypd shows up and then they
scattered
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
cops are here are they mad that they are
being denied service or that they
it's not even really clear like what
they're mad about at this exact moment i
mean
oh okay they're inside without masks so
i assume these are the anti-masters okay
[Music]
i guess the implication is that because
he has the martin luther king shirt on
that
he
by
insisting on going in without a vaccine
and without a mask
that he is like martin luther king in
some way is that what we are to glean
from the presence of the sweatshirt
anybody know
maybe he's just mad that they're using
liquid smoke and that there's not really
a fr a flame broiled element to the
whopper that could be it as well
okay let's watch a little
big
more
[Music]
[Applause]
they might as well be protesting that
american cheese isn't really cheese but
it's a processed dairy product
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay now police have arrived
[Applause]
[Applause]
you know all these you know all these
people who say whenever there's a
shooting
we would have been better off if more
people there had guns would have been
much better and we say
that's crazy
like police showing up
when there's multiple people with guns
seems problematic
even in this situation
just from watching this video it's not
completely clear to me who's what and
what what's going on
uh like some people just seem to be mad
at the fact that there are protesters
she's worried
you can't tell me that i can't i really
lost my job
you can't tell me that i can't eat okay
all right so there's that
um here is
january sixth writer mitchell bosch
commits to being arrested for
trespassing at a burger king
uh
okay anybody shocked that there's
overlap between january 6th rioters and
anti-vaxx anti-mask protesters is that
surprising to anybody
we are gentlemen ladies and gentlemen
here
we will leave gracefully after the nypd
leaves legal do the right thing
sometimes you can't follow the law per
se
sir
you don't have to do it
you're illegal right gentlemen you're a
lawyer
you know
yeah
what is this guy talking about you know
you don't have to do it that way give
them the advice we will leave
we will leave
we will leave all right
we do not want to be arrested
we want to walk out with y'all yeah
we'll walk out together yeah no walk out
the
the police have to treat these people
like children yes we'll all leave
together
yes let's go
oh no
they don't want nothing
they don't want no form of
[Applause]
the strategy with little kids
where
instead of being like you have to do
this as opposed to nothing you give them
a choice you give them a false choice
where it's like it's bedtime no it's not
yes it is instead you go
little little susie little little
mordechai
did you want to read a book
before bed
or did you want to
you know have a warm milk before bed and
it's like well oh i i can choose i'd
rather there it's sort of the same thing
here we give you
whatever it is okay
i'm i'm giving you ample time
but i can't be here all night i got back
and forth so
we want y'all to leave and we will leave
we mean we gonna let a half hour
ago right we've been we got to make sure
right and you you could make a
difference because you don't have to
hear the telegram
no okay
you don't have to listen to legal it's
it's unbelievable
um i don't even know that we want to
watch too many more of these let's check
this one out
we'll be arrested
people are watching this all over the
world
i just want to get this on paper so we
came here to order food
the manager called you guys because we
wanted to order food a public place that
he wanted to actually pay them no no
it's moving to the public it's so bad
for the public
see that's one of those things where
where it's like wait a second hold on
if it's not by appointment only then
there's no rules you can impose that's
like saying wait a second oh you can't
tell me to wear a shirt in here
because you're open it's not like it's
by appointment only so
it's it doesn't matter
the these are imaginary
distinctions they're telling us right we
have not committed
okay all right man these people are
really really boring um here's another
one after two were arrested this
anti-vaxxer repeatedly yelled
kyle hitler at the nypd the anti-vaxx
crowd also tried to shame the nypd with
the veteran status of one of the people
arrested let's see
[Music]
[Music]
the nazis were just following orders
just following orders
following orders just following orders
just like a good old-fashioned nazi
a good old-fashioned nazi
[Music]
shame on
your children
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
so that's that um so we're gonna get
away from that uh and then i've got one
more this one this is a really really
stunning video i'm gonna show you in a
moment let me make sure i'm caught up on
thank yous i wanna thank havana triple 2
for gifting a sub on twitch that puts us
at 18. also a big thank you to connor
hill connor just signed up on my website
with the coupon code obama
and his new member number 19 remember
that at the top of the hour just 39
minutes from now we will be doing our
final viewer town hall of the year it
will be streaming live on the pacman
live youtube channel
and we will also um
the calls themselves will be taking
place via discord
davidpakman.com
discord so there's like five or six
different reasons to sign up today one
get the get get the subscription in
before the end of the year so you've got
an extra this is the time you know like
on those american express cards where
it's like members since the year and it
doesn't matter if you sign up on january
1 or december 31 you get the full year
signing up now gets you in on 2021 and
four days from now you will already be
in your second year because this is not
like licensing or life insurance
we give you credit for the whole year
it's it's incred we really shouldn't
actually but you know that's a story for
a different day
um
and it's just a great a great day to do
it all right i also want to say thanks
to chris nelson chris just signed up
with a
very powerful level two full-price
membership
on my website and nolan just gifted two
more subscriptions on twitch putting us
at 22
which is uh
it's really really something else all
right this if i understand correctly
this is a video of a one woman here
slapping an 80 year old on a flight from
tampa to atlanta
i think this happened over over the
christmas holiday
someone told me that this woman is
actually
a known model does anybody know about
that can anybody comment on that
like this is like a well-known person
here who does the slapping we're going
to watch this in a second
let me see here
model slaps 80 year old on plane
patricia cornwall
delta karen is the nickname i'm not a
big fan of that
who is patricia cornwall
uh
yeah former baywatch
baywatch actress
okay anyway all right so she slaps an 80
year old
these flights are getting completely out
of control
oh wait a second but this guy wasn't
wearing his mask so now i'm now i'm
trying to figure out who's in the wrong
here maybe everybody is
so she's yelling at this guy about his
mask but her mask's off as well people
are going crazy
goddamn characters
[Music]
oh he's eating and drinking people
people take advantage of that so much i
was recently on some flights and people
will just hold their cup like this while
watching a movie
because then if the flight attendant
walks by it sort of looks like you're in
the middle of drinking it it's it's
crazy what people are doing
tell him
[ __ ]
sir
wow open hand slap in the face this
guy's
80. as soon as we get it later you're
going to jail
[Music]
here this is insane
[Music]
but she punched me
[Music]
like why won't she put her mask on you
know because i like if we grant that if
we stipulate that it's legitimate to be
concerned about this guy not wearing his
mask he claims he's eating and drinking
shouldn't she
even just in principle keep the mask on
the whole time
it's sad what's happening in society oh
policeman he went crazy on the airplane
punch this man in the face spit on those
crashes
pour high water on my leg yes
okay so i mean that's geez that's really
that's really something uh something
strange
i want to say thanks to devin williamson
for signing up on my website with the
coupon code obama
devon is new member number 23 today also
oh well we're seeing some pretty big
membership dumps here evelyn lafone
just signed up on my website as well and
will get priority access during today's
viewer town hall
over on twitch i want to say thank you
to dinan cleo
grimm reefer and jen here
for three twitch prime subscriptions
also putting us at 27 and a lot on the
line we are building momentum and trying
to get to what by the end of the day of
the week would be five consecutive
streams each day we get to a hundred we
lock in another stream for the next day
and helping us get there is jay tandaway
who's been around a really long time
gifting another five via twitch
it's a christmas miracle it's a festivus
miracle
uh very much appreciate that very very
much appreciate that uh here's something
just kind of funny we don't have to make
like a big deal out of this but
the stock market has been on a tear this
past year i mean really you know from 30
to 36 000 in the last year that's about
a 20 percent gain
and just as a reminder remember when
trump was making predictions like these
if biden wins you're gonna have a stock
market collapse the likes of which
you've never had another record day on
wall street stocks rallying to kick off
the final trading week of the year it's
69th this year the last time that
happened yeah so that didn't happen let
me see if i can fact-base trump search
here it is we can actually find like for
example biden wins 401k
oh man
hold on biden 401k
yeah
so here's some examples of the things
trump was saying
and i think we're leading can you
believe in early voting
but
has any oh that's a shock oh that's a
big story they're saying we have to get
more people out we have maybe i
shouldn't say that people are watching
now we're doing good no but
anybody here
vote for sleepy joe biden
this election is a choice between
a crippling depression or a historic
boom it is you have a depression
all that money all those 401ks they're
going to go right down to tubes throw it
out yeah record highs
record highs
you you could say that the market is is
overbought
but very very wrong so far it's a choice
between a deadly biden lockdown he wants
to lock down the country all right
anyway you guys got the idea so there
were all these different things i think
also trump said that there would be no
heating
uh yeah remember this
this was really weird and actually most
of them are our supporters trying to
cause a little havoc but that's uh
we don't want that
biden has vowed to abolish the entire
u.s oil industry no more fracking no
mining no heating no clean coal no
heating there would be no heating under
under uh biden and there was one where i
think he said no windows
uh
yeah he said that a bunch of times
because it has to go through the
president okay
so you know
what the heck is going on here
to worry about it the election
is a choice between a trump super
recovery that's what we're having or a
biden depression if he gets in with his
craziness that he's talking about with
his massive tax and you know where the
money's going to the green new deal
they want to rip down thousands of
buildings and rebuild them with very
small windows very specific
i want my beautiful window i want my
view i don't want to have small windows
it is the crazy so windows sinks showers
they're they're looking at all of it
very strongly so anyway
um
the stock market doing well now you
could say well the stock market doesn't
tell us everything about the economy i
would agree with you that that's the
case no matter who's president and we've
talked about that many many many times
before i want to say thank you to cindy
weeks
cindy weeks just signed up on my website
with the coupon code obama
and his new member number 33 also lisa
rule just signed up on my website with
the coupon code obama obama and his new
member number 34 remember that at the
top of the hour 29 minutes from now will
be the live david pakman show viewer
town hall it will be only
on the pacman live youtube channel i
want to make sure people understand this
at the top of the hour this stream will
stop
a new stream will start only
on the new
youtube channel and that's where it will
stream everybody who wants to call in
can do so via our discord just a little
sampling of what's over on the pacman
live youtube channel here was a um
clip where we looked at jimmy from
philly calling some drug show check this
out a couple
from
jimmy from philly
david jimmy from philly white
destiny has held into some kind of drug
show
yeah and
he sent it to me
here he is talking to a drug guy
again for the content man keep it up
cheers my pleasure
so let's see we've got
jimmy from
philly let's bring
europe um
i'm about to speak
hey there jimmy
hey doll i'm doing all right jimmy how
are you
i'm doing excellent mate
good go to it man
so uh
i've been doing two to four hundred
micrograms of lsd for the last two and a
half years every saturday night oh wow
okay
even the drug guy is shocked by what
jimmy is doing
that would be heavy use i guess
but
i don't know that
i know a lot of people say that it
teaches them something about themselves
and i don't know that i would say that
but
two things i can definitely say
i'm much happier and way more creative
there's no doubt about your creativity
through the roof i like to make people
laugh
and uh
i always wanted to start a youtube
channel right but i was just like like
what am i going to talk about i mean now
you can't shut me up but
anyway so um yeah make sure you're
subscribed to the pacman live youtube
channel this is where the town hall will
be at the top of the hour okay um i did
want to check in p i've gotten a report
that destiny is now in
florida
and that he has a whole new setup i
haven't seen that so let's check it out
oh
seems like nothing's going on let's see
destiny youtube
let's see if he's live here where we can
scroll let's see what destiny has been
up to
sporting games if you played him upload
the bonds before i grab you by your neck
from the other side of the monitor and
unsubscribe
what game is this is this like a dark
version of the sims i don't even know
what this is about
is weird
let's see what else he did today
trying to self-teach piano how would you
go about it from what you know now i
don't know learn your skills okay that's
important don't short cut that [ __ ]
boom
man let's do some stations so i have a
few more uh other like pointed questions
i suppose
so uh our class completed an activity
that showed that we have a great deal of
interest in money
and helping those that we care about
how do you feel about these things in
high school and is it any different
now um do kids call it i just like kind
of interview him for school projects is
that what's going on here
what your outlook on on money back then
and yeah so to gain an appreciation for
money there's like two there's like two
different
there are like different ways that we
view money based on what stage in life
we're at and you can talk about it but
it's really impossible to understand
until you've been there so like
when you're in high school or grade
school
i guess give you money in terms of the
allowance that you get for video games
like they're you're you're thinking like
well 60 or 80 is a game or maybe you
know 20 dollars a night going to the
movies and getting popcorn um
or you know maybe you have like these
concepts in your head once you start
working a job for me at least
money i started to see money through
more of like a time
thing
um so when i started wearing mcdonald's
i think way way back in the day i think
the minimum wage was either 5 15 or 5 25
an hour you know so something would have
cost me you know forty dollars or fifty
dollars that's like a long day of work
for me that's like a ten hour shift
that's a lot of work to get that much
money
um
later on maybe you'll start to see money
through the lens of like bills
like uh you know i've got all right so
doing some personal finance stuff so
there's that let's also check on what
hassan is up to let's see oh
ready he's also a what
five-minute countdown what the [ __ ] now
what are you talking about are you ready
are you [ __ ] ready for what too many
questions
[Music]
what is this
what the hell is going on
oh um
i'm not a fish
all right so that's what's happening
over on
uh the hassan stream
yeah
well the reason is that with the
definitely interesting
um
all right very good i wanna say thank
you to snappy tam
for subscribing via twitch prime your
number 35 today snappy tam says i've
been a website member for about a year
but i'm happy to give my bezos bucks to
the team too yeah guys we have until six
o'clock to get to a hundred to lock in a
stream for tomorrow at six we start the
town hall maybe we'll keep it going at
that point um
i i actually don't know that we're gonna
do it and it's sort of depressing
yeah i don't know and people are like
david it might not happen
i'm not stupid
i'm not stupid we basically have 22
minutes for 65.
that means 2 per minute roughly 2 per
minute or
yeah maybe someone will will dump in
hold on do i even have that clip
and what happened
big massive dumps right somebody might
dump in a bunch but i i'm not i'm not uh
super optimistic okay yes i have
voicemails i have voicemails i have
voicemails let's get to voicemails just
a few we're not going to do a ton of
them
um let's see what we got here
david i don't believe anything you say
about fruit because you say granny smith
apples are the best apples and you are
wrong why does that guy have the worst
absolutely the worst audio
it's bizarre
hello ladies this is anna the
argentinian from miami i'm
watching your omicron everywhere video
and there are other reasons why
the numbers are not real we can't know
the real numbers is the at home best
i was thinking all those people who are
getting that i i tweeted about this
earlier
right now when we look at the covid
numbers
and they are kind of going nuclear and
they're off i mean like look at this
this is crazy
understand that if you just buy a bunch
of those like abbott binax tests and do
them at home
and you get a positive
if you don't report that if you don't go
in then to a hospital to confirm your
diagnosis via pcr
it doesn't even show up here so when i
see oh
when i see 289 305 000 cases in a day
i'm assuming it's probably 600 000 cases
because there are so many people not
even getting tested who have it and then
so many people just getting a positive
on a home test and calling it a day so
this that it is not even close it's not
these are not even close to the real
numbers without a doubt
um
okay
see what else we got hi david i call you
regularly and it's
a fact at this point in time
that the reason people are not being
vaccinated in this country it's just
they purely have a fear of needles
all this conspiracy stuff garbage
is nothing more
than
my dog ate my homework
is is fear of needles really that common
i mean i know some people have it but
let's see prevalence of fear of needles
uh let's take a look at what percentage
fear of needles a systematic review
um
[Music]
119 original research articles is a
meta-analysis
35 contain sufficient information
the majority of children exhibited
needle fear
while prevalence estimates for needle
fear range from 20 to 50 in adolescence
20 to 30 in young adults needle fear
decreases with age
both needle fear and needle phobia
were more prevalent in females than
males
avoidance of influenza vaccine because
of needle fear occurred in 16 percent of
patients 27 of hospital employees 18 of
workers at long-term care facilities 8
of health care workers needle fear was
common when undergoing venipuncture
blood donation and those with chronic
conditions requiring injection
conclusion fear of needles is common in
patients requiring preventive care and
in those undergoing treatment greater
attention should be directed to
interventions which alleviate alleviate
fear in high-risk groups okay so it i
mean it's it's it it's a thing um how
many people are not getting a covet
vaccine as a result
um
yeah and people saying that there's
there's a more detailed way to read it i
understand i'm just seeing if there's
even anything that suggests it's a
majority and it doesn't seem to be i
want to say thank you to seth mackenzie
seth just signed up on my website using
the coupon code obama
also want to say thank you to margot
cabot who just gifted a subscription via
twitch and is number 37 today
very much appreciate that
let's listen to a couple
more voicemails
hi david darren from california i was
just curious how we're supposed to take
this so-called war on christmas
seriously yeah when we have uh melania
trump
uh on record saying who gives an f about
christmas are you effing kidding me i do
all this stuff and no one cares
um i don't know if you're familiar with
the phone call but it's a phone call
with her friend and she's complaining
about
setting up christmas and everything um
so just again how can we take the war on
syria okay yeah
regardless of melania's opinion the war
on christmas is not something that we
can take seriously we don't even need to
worry about
what melania is saying uh okay let's
listen to a couple others let's see here
hey david it's there for mass
wow what great timing the covenant and
flu super combo pack is available just
in time for christmas
almost like they had it all ready to go
or something line up and be an [ __ ]
get the double shot now he will be sorry
okay so eric continuing anti-vaxx
propaganda
but i just feel like
it would like if
people were treated differently
based on how they look um
and you know maybe there being some
discrepancy about race
um there would be
a lot of people who would you know
obviously stand away from
you know helping out society in which
they're not i i never know what
whitney's talking about i really don't
okay
but before we talk about like
what books are like up and coming right
now
i think that you need to do some
thinking in the matter of
the context and which things are written
um for example
when trump says stuff and it's like
maybe
negative or funny
or
um
you know all of those things it's very
iconic and he's scottish geez um it's
just whitney and eric from mass calling
back to back
hey david what's up that's eric from ass
i was wondering uh when you go hard like
that on fox um i can see what you you
mean but did you ever think maybe
they're trying to speak for the american
people
who don't have a voice and stuff like
that to get them to stand up
they had to do what they had to do but
what is he talking about look it's just
back and forth between these two
if there's like um prescription drugs
um that you can give people
and it does something like to their
hormones to make them either like female
or male
what if they start like putting that
kind of stuff into
the antidepressants right or something
like that
and they just start like
regulating the dose
and calling it like something else
well
um
jeez
i i don't know
hi david i'm afraid i have to correct
you on something
you said that
the name of this variant should be
pronounced omicron and not omicron
not defending the president's
pronunciation but you should know that
in ancient greek there are two
vowels there's a short o and a long o
and omicron which is the short o is
called omicron because it's an ah and
then micron which means short or small
like a microscope the other one of
course is the omega and mega of course
means all right omicron or as some now
know it the omicron the omicron
uh
okay
hey david now before you start taking
discord calls you actually to call some
actual physical phone numbers yeah i'm a
little concerned that you're guilty of
massive amount of wiretapping because
you actually recorded those phone calls
david
um yeah both parties knew it was being
recorded so it was fine although i
appreciate the concern i want to say
thanks to mark smith
mark just grabbed a membership on my
website joinpackman.com okay just a
couple more and then we are going to get
set up for the town hall which is um
which is starting soon
hi david this is laura
i was wondering how could donald trump
win in 2024 if a million of his
supporters have already died and we've
still got three more years before
well remember that you know of the 800
000 that have died it's it's not all
republicans at all at all at all at all
so the the numbers don't quite check out
there laura i hate to break it to you
but you could get to the point where it
would make a difference uh within a
particular
um within a particular race we've talked
about uh those numbers okay it's time
for the david pakman show viewer town
hall so we're we're gonna end this
stream
i'm gonna start a stream over on the
pacman live youtube channel if you want
to watch if you want to join that's the
only place okay it's the
youtube.compacmanlive
it's the other channel the other channel
youtube.compacmanlive
and then davidpakman.com discord to
actually call in
so we're gonna this stream is ending
we're gonna go to pacman live and it'll
start at the top of the hour see
everybody